[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nuestra invitada yulia timochenko la ex
primera ministra de ucrania
nos habla desde kiev donde permanece
para enfrentar la agresión rusa y señora
timoshenko gracias por estar con
nosotros
si usted sigue la política y ahora
participa en la defensa de su país
cuál es su estado de ánimo en este
momento explicó un momento muy duro muy
difícil para ustedes y sus compatriotas
y fue compartido
en lo que piensa los ucranianos aquí
actualmente es en cómo pudo suceder eso
en el siglo 21 en medio de europa
en una capital europea vemos que la
capital es bombardeada con misiles
hay asaltos con tanques y los civiles
inocentes son asesinados como es posible
que el mundo haya permitido eso
y la segunda cosa en la que piensan los
ucranianos y yo es cómo defender
nuestras familias
y nuestra independencia la independencia
de nuestro país
los jaibos se imagina usted al ejército
ruso en su país en la capital
donde usted se encuentra en este momento
de ninguna manera
y nadie podía imaginar esta situación
pero es evidente que ocurrió tal como
puede ver
cuando se tomó crime hay tumbas
nadie se imaginó que podría lanzar esta
guerra de envergadura nadie lo imaginaba
pero actualmente los misiles y las
bombas caen encima nuestro
nuestra gente es asesinada
ponemos estándar y el mundo debe unirse
para ponerle fin a esto
y para usted señora timoshenko cuál es
la raíz del problema que estamos
viviendo hoy en día y creo que la razón
principal por la cual esto está
ocurriendo es porque put en el kremlin
rusia
por un motivo desconocido decidieron que
ucrania independiente
hace parte de su país de su patria como
dicen
y que si no pueden tomarse ucrania por
la vía política
deben tener el derecho de tomarse
ucrania por la vía militar
es un lugar a ucrania y revivir esta
parte de la unión soviética
para los ucranianos y el mundo entero
estoy segura lo impedirán
hablemos sobre vladimir putin
hasta donde llegará según usted
cuando observo la violencia que cae
sobre ucrania
con las bombas sobre los jardines de
niños
las escuelas los hospitales
los disparos y la destrucción de las
viviendas de civiles
y comprendo y comparto el dolor de cada
ucraniano
y con él
y todo el mundo y le agradecemos a su
país y a todos aquellos que comparten
nuestro dolor y
deseo que nos unamos para detener todo
esto
que el mundo entero se una para ponerle
fin a esta violencia
porque ucrania es el corazón y si le
permitimos a putin perforar este corazón
si no permitimos que ucrania se defienda
fracasaremos
es importante defender al mundo entero
en el terrorismo de esta violencia
señora timoshenko usted nos habla sobre
quién usted está en ucrania ucrania se
defenderá hasta el final
que puede decirnos al respecto
dentro de unas cuantas horas la asamblea
general de naciones unidas se reunirá
es muy importante para nosotros que las
fuerzas para mantener la paz sean
limitadas
y puedan venir a ucrania
es muy importante que el mundo entero
nos acompañe
y acompaña a los ucranianos que el mundo
entero detenga al agresor
es importante cerrar el espacio aéreo
ucraniano para cualquier aeronave rusa
y cualquier misil
porque actualmente es una amenaza
directa
solamente para ucrania sino para toda
europa
contamos con cuatro centrales nucleares
y 15 unidades de energía de este tipo y
si el ejército de putin tiene la
intención de bombardear nuestras
centrales nucleares como
será una tragedia para todo el
continente
es por eso que nos dirigimos al mundo y
a la otan
para que cierren el espacio aéreo
ucraniano
para que cualquier aeronave o misil
rusos no pueden caer sobre nuestras
cabezas
qué representa para usted la amenaza
nuclear de putin
y
hoy vemos la guerra que inició contra
ucrania
y esa guerra es decisiva para él
nosotros ucrania somos los primeros en
resistir frente a putin
pero creo que hará uso de todas sus
posibilidades para lograr su cometido
y es por ello que mencioné las centrales
nucleares y la posibilidad de que ordene
bombardeo sobre ellas
y por eso no es posible dejar a ucrania
sola frente a este ejército tan poderoso
agradecemos al mundo entero su apoyo
las sanciones contra el régimen de putin
y la entrega de material a ucrania
pero debemos volver a abordar el tema de
las fuerzas de paz de naciones unidas
porque se hace contingente lo llega a
ucrania
es el espacio aéreo ucraniano no es
cerrado
para problemas para el continente y para
el mundo
ucrania renunció al arma nuclear y
memorando de budapest
fue firmado por acan ya rusia eeuu
mido francia de alemania
y he dicho memorando contenía garantías
para ucrania
y
el territorio y la paz de ucrania
con la protección
y
creo que el mundo empieza a movilizarse
pero el ejército ruso es tan grande
que necesitamos apoyo para cerrar el
espacio aéreo ucraniano para cualquier
aeronave o misil ruso
y tenemos de peluche
y muchísimos urtáin de hackers
para terminar cuál es el mensaje para el
pueblo ucraniano
ya
quisiera dirigirme a cada ucraniano
ustedes son valientes y son fuertes
ama la libertad y viven en un país
democrático
amar a sus familias ya sus hijos
aguanten por favor
defiendan nuestra libertad
porque estamos unidos somos fuertes
y quisiera que estemos convencidos de
que ganaremos que ucrania será un país
próspero en el centro de europa
un país libre aguanten y consigan esta
victoria queridos ucranianos
señora timochenko gracias por haber
estado con nosotros en france 24 y
ustedes los invitamos a que permanezcan
con nuestra información
y
[Música]